Which party will I vote for in the elections I will vote for the socialist
party I will vote for the PSOE I will vote for the PSOE I will vote for
socialists for the PSOE why well Look because the whole issue of youth how
they are doing eh I like it very much and I have always been at home I have
grown up with socialist people and I have it clear because I think he is the
only one who will go forward that we always get better things in work eh
women eh the LGTBI is that in everything we always move forward with them
for me there is no other party this is at least to give the money to the
others and and the popular and the others are only left for them they are
the only ones I opened 1 company a few years ago and it was and we were
about to close and we were 5 partners because it was 1 cooperative and they
gave us 500 well 500 000 pesetas at lost bottom and we could continue
working and besides my father is 94 years old and the man says that to the
right has not uploaded anything and since he is in it because in so long he
has raised 1 lot of money with us they raised him eh I do not know how many
years €3 I was talking to him and now they have raised him 1 lot of course
I think these people do something.